[Music]
1783 from
australia
all right let's go knight f6 i don't
know what okay well what we're playing
has been determined for us f4 so this is
an attempt at a stonewall
uh this has been around for a while
white wants to go e3 c3 and the one
thing i don't recommend well there's
actually there's a couple of things we
can do against the stone well the first
is we could play d5 control the e4
square i actually don't like playing d5
against the stonewall and even if you're
not a kings indian player
i like the king's indian setup against
the stonewall you don't have to be a
king's indian player and they should
play c5 cd and de in order to be able to
play the king's indian against the
stonewall so let's
make the standard king's indian moves d6
castle it doesn't matter the order we'll
play d6
maybe castles was a little more flexible
doesn't really matter bishop d3 now the
funny thing is
i'm going to allow white to play e4 on
the next move and that would lead to a
perk up a tempo i kind of play the perk
anyway so i don't really mind that
um
and i feel like somebody who plays d4
and f4 won't be familiar with the ideas
of the perk for white so we'll castle
i'm not afraid of e4
and now
what is the benefit of putting the pawn
on d6 rather than d5 well what idea can
be prepared with the move d6 what are we
trying to prepare so first of all you
could play c5 but that's not my favorite
to c5 can just be met with c3 much like
in the london but what we need to
prepare is e5 not immediately we can't
play it yet
we'll prepare it with knight knight b8
to c6 the point is when we play e5 we
cause a much bigger explosion in the
center does that make sense because we
attack both of these pawns and we
threaten a fork
so e5 just does a lot more than c5 in
this particular instance so let's get
our knight out let's get our knight out
and now we're ready to play e5 now you
might look at this and say wait a minute
white has one two three attackers and
there's only two defenders so how is
that possible but if you calculate a
little further you'll see that in order
to quantico win the pawn white has to
totally ruin his structure and will win
the pawn on e5 back
very easily
all right and i can show this after the
game in more detail but we can safely
play e5 without worrying about losing a
pawn
okay our opponent continues to play very
fast
knight bd2
now
we have several options
what seems to be a
pretty reasonable follow-up here to
reinforce the threat of e4 yeah rookie 8
is a pretty inoffensive move that we can
always throw in in these positions and
maybe we can play ed later and open up
the e file right now i think it's time
for us to
to start
uh taking well actually no i think i
think we should first develop this
bishop we haven't developed our bishop
yet
and
i feel like bishop b6 would be decent
here
i i don't i know some of you are
probably thinking bishop g4 but then why
can just play h3 and chase it away there
is an alternate way of developing the
bishop here which is b6 bishop b7
fianchettoing the other bishop and then
the bishop is going to aim at the e4
square i quite like that idea b6 and
this is upon sacrifice let's see if our
opponent figures out how to win the pawn
okay no i'll show after the game knight
g5 an intimidating looking move but is
it actually scary i don't think it is i
don't see what it threatens
i think we can safely continue our
development probably he's gonna go
bishop c4 but then we can very simply
defend our pawn with rook e8 to e7
knight d5 would give up f7 potentially
so you'd have to be very careful about
that move always consider what you know
you're moving at night right what are
you opening up some doors close others
open that's a very common type of
blunder 94 that's a mistake now what
should we do should we take the knight
obvious
simple straightforward question we take
the knight
yes we should we should take the knight
and i always like to do this asking a
question and you guys are used to like
your english teacher asking that and the
answer is always no
but my answer is sometimes yes you
should take the knight and the reason is
simple by taking that you're exposing an
attack on the other night knight takes
queen takes g5 what does that mean well
that means white has to recapture our
knight with his knight
and in turn that takes the pressure off
of the f-pawn and if you look one step
further you'll see that black is a very
natural and very strong way to continue
after knight takes e4 if you're a king's
indian player this move should occur to
you
very naturally what am i talking about
am i not afraid of knight takes f7 yeah
i calculated it if he plays it i'll i'll
talk about it but i don't think he'll
play knight f7 here it's maybe he will
but then we'll talk about that if he
plays it f5 yeah i have f5 chasing the
knight away and then potentially e4 or
even he takes d4
and we we
totally push back his pieces okay so
definitely our opponent is contemplating
knight takes f7 which is an intermediate
move
which doesn't look
dumb at all right it attacks the queen
and white has two attackers on the
knight on e4 so no matter where our
queen moves even if it moves to h4
it it appears that white can
capture the knight with the bishop
but i calculated oh maybe not one second
i might have
miscalculated
let me think let me think for a moment i
didn't entirely miscalculate it's just
that
we might have to go into an end game
which i don't really want to do
i don't see a way to avoid it sadly we
he out calculated me
late i've been out calculated a few
times in in the last couple of games in
the speed run
uh so what i saw here yeah i been dec
got it so i was dentist i was intending
queen h4 and i'll tell you what i missed
so queen h4
um
we nature what's the idea
after bishop takes c4 and we will play
this move okay our opponent is thinking
i don't know what oh crap wait there's a
move here
missed the smothered made idea we might
lose this game if he finds a move that
it okay no he doesn't find it
queen b3 there was very scary yeah
knight takes d4
and this is what i calculated attacking
the queen exposing the attack on the
bishop and after he takes d4 i thought
bishop takes e4 and we're fine
i completely forgot about queen b3
which sets up unstoppable discovered
check against the king and a potential
smothered mate yeah i messed this up i
mean knight takes e4 was just a mistake
simply speaking a mistake i
underestimated nine of seven so what
we'll have to do after ed
what will we have to do so
we we discovered that bishop takes e4 is
a potentially big mistake
is there an alternative do we panic yeah
we have to take the bishop with the
queen
we have to take the bishop of the queen
and that offers a queen trade and then
he can take on e5 and basically
everything is traded and that's that's
essentially a dead draw but we'll try to
win that end game
yeah we we panic
okay edie
yeah we have to bite the bullet because
bishop takes c4 he'll find queen b3 and
then we're busted now if he plays queen
q3 gets mated
okay now i'm gonna have to prove my
medal here by winning a
completely like an end game that's
totally devoid of winning chance oh whoa
whoa whoa
that cannot be good
queen f2 just leaving our battery intact
no but this i think this just loses
what does this lose to what should we do
first of all i think we can play e takes
d4
but then there might be knight h6 check
and that's a very nasty
we'll put
yeah that is a nasty idea because that
force is a trade it's a shortcut fate
just wrote that fade and
we're pinning the knight now we're not
threatening rook takes f7 i think some
of you might think we are
because then queen takes f7 as check
what we are threatening is bishop b7 to
d5
picking up picking off the knight i
don't think that can be
defended
yeah but this was i'm disappointed in my
quality of play there i did something
very seriously wrong maybe if he
encountering the bishop was
fundamentally the wrong idea too slow i
think queen f2
speaking of the course i've noticed that
people in like the 17 1800 range tend to
make this kind of mistake often and i
don't even know how to describe this
mistake
i would call it
okay so the comparison i would draw is
when you when i move to
there's a name for this in psychology
but when you move to let's say this
different floor in the same apartment
building you for the first couple of
times you essentially go up to the old
floor um or an office building or
whatever okay i think you know what i
think is even better than bishop d5
because bishop d5 maybe he'll go rook 81
we have to deal with we have to decide
where to put the queen
is there an alternative so what should
we do we want to avoid bishop d5 rook
ae1 but we still want to attack the
knight is there anything else that could
attack the knight yeah queen d5
we can do it with a queen and that
violates a rule that i like to
talk up which is that you should
accomplish tasks with the piece of
lowest value but this is an exception to
the rule because the queen
is vulnerable to begin with so we're
doing two things at once we're making
the queen safer and we're attacking the
knight and winning the night
so
sometimes this kind of thing happens
when you're attacking
i feel like players think that they have
to keep attacking no matter what and
that all queen trades have to be ruled
out at all costs when you're attacking
you got to keep attacking
and what ends up happening is that they
ignore
what's actually going on right ignoring
for example the fact that i now have
this battery and that there's no longer
any attack
so
this lack of flexibility i think is
quite common at this level
where you you embark on a particular
type way of playing either attack or
you know this is how i'm playing and
then
this lack of flexibility often
causes you to lose objectivity and i
have definitely i can find some examples
from my games
okay well that's a
we could even play bishop takes e5 but
let's snag the lady
attackers neglect that's interesting
so what should we do now let's let's try
to be
disciplined
how should we convert this what should
we do
well what we shouldn't do is bishop
takes e5 i don't like bishop takes e5 i
don't like the concept of giving away
the dark squared bishop because
those of you were the keen tactical eye
could see that bishop h6 could become a
problem and then why could create some
made threats on f8 so there's two
options we can go rook f8 and trade one
pair of rooks love it let's start with
rook f8 no nothing to lose there and
then you guys are also naming the second
move which is c7 c5 just when i look at
this knight the first thing i noticed
that it's defended by the pawn and you
just the undermining concept is so
important in so many different types of
positions
or after rook af1 you ask yourself how
is the position changed you don't lose
sight of the whole board and you see
that the a2 pawn is now hanging so after
the trade you could very safely take
that pawn in a2 and just start grabbing
everything on the queen side
okay so knight f3 has happened
so he brought the knight back himself
now
i think that that is a good move that is
a good move now we have a really fancy
move we could play if we wanted to
but well again
i struggled sometimes to verbalize what
i would do here because there are so
many approaches
to winning the game and so many
individual good moves already you got it
g5 and try and go g4
then i struggled to say well this is how
i would play
the move that i would play in a
classical game is c5
i like the move c5 now you might say
well wait a minute wasn't the point of
this move to undermine the knight you've
already done that why are you doing that
now
it's hard to explain i mean i want to
get rid of the d-pawn so that our queen
gets more real estate in the center i
want dc queen takes e5 pinning the rook
and threatening to double capture on f3
because of the pin
this pawn on d4 is holding us back a
little bit and i want to get rid of it i
hopefully that makes sense
and open up files i mean the more files
are open the easier it's going to be to
convert an extra queen
our black bishop is not good it's not
going to be good even after dc because
then there's going to be a c3 pawn
that's going to be staring at but at
least it's going to control the d4
square
i have a great example of a im against
me who did exactly what i described
and
it's a it's a very high level example
it's not a simple example but i think if
you
listen carefully it's quite instructive
how chess psychology works
sometimes
and how you can use it against people
and you can use it
to defend really really bad positions at
times
and then as he's thinking i'll find the
game
okay rookie one
well i think it's time for us to
grab
and now grab
again pinned now i've briefly checked
rookie 8 check making sure that there's
nothing here you go king f7
always anytime you abandon your back
rank you always just need to check real
fast okay rookie checking f7
okay rook f1 well we don't need to take
actually we kind of do because b4 is a
threat we have a very fancy move here
that we could play but i let's play it
simple let's take it and now after rook
takes f2 i really like the move i really
like the look of bishop g7 to e5 who can
tell me what the idea is i don't know
why our opponent is taking so much time
on these moves
bishop takes h2 very good
how did i see that well
again
a lot of people just sort of passively
notice the pin
and they think okay can i attack the
rook with my bishop if i understand the
thinking of some people they say well
can i go bishop d4
no there's a pawn on c3 can i get rid of
the pawn on c3 not really
and that's it they sort of filed us away
into the back of their mind but i don't
stop there i say in what
sort of second order way can i use the
pin what does the pin mean that means
the king is defending the rook that
means it's kind of overloaded that means
if i go after the h2 pawn there could be
an overloading tactic and i'm really
over over explaining this that's not
actually what i'm thinking this is all
happening subconsciously but i think
that's the gist of it well it doesn't
even matter that queen takes f2 as a
fork just the fact that it wins the rook
is already good enough but i think this
is a very important distinction which is
that
a lot of people
they think well
if i see the same tactical phenomena
that gm see why am i not seeing these
complicated tactics and by the way you
can still
take on h2 doesn't matter
and one of the things that
happens subconsciously high level
players they don't just look at the
tactical phenomenon itself they
understand how it can be used to
accomplish other things
or how it can be used as only one
component in a combination b4 i saw this
move
how should we proceed
so we need to move the queen and defend
the bishop and we can go queen e5 or
queen d6
i like windy 6 because if bishop h6
happens we can even move our bishop back
and sacrifice on f8
and hold on to the bishop we can also go
queen g3 check and i think we'll be able
to win the bishop check check
let's go queen g3 and then at the end we
can even drop the bishop back to d6 to
defend oh yeah queen h3 what am i
talking about this is just a fork
this is a fork
okay good i mean not not a good game at
all
but it is what it is
so
just to take a look here
i will be honest i haven't analyzed the
the um
stonewall how to play against it
properly so me playing the kings indian
is is sort of just
kind of improvising
okay so castle's castles again white
could play e4 here and maybe white is
even better according to the engine but
i i like this from the perspective of a
perk player you know black is up a tempo
on
this position
so let's put push e4 to the side for now
so castle's knight c6 i think this is
all good e5
takes takes nbd2
i think rookie 8 is normal
honestly i think in this position b6
misses the mark
it's it's a little too slow and i i just
didn't pay attention to my f7 pawn
enough
so b6
knight g5 and here
after bishop b7 knight d4 i think the
real mistake came in this position
what should we have done instead of
knight takes e4
well it's hard to say actually it's not
so easy to find a move
because if you play h6 then i'm quite
worried about takes takes
and now this move knight takes f7
and bishop takes g6 check although this
is not as scary as it looks because at
the end of the day you have two pieces
for a rook
and you're consolidated
so maybe h6 actually works
um
takes takes
bishop g6 and no then you go hg
i think h6 might work and if white takes
and goes knight e4
then you drop back and but now we get
bishop c4 and
there's pressure there's a lot of
pressure on the pawn
this is not this isn't pleasant i mean
this isn't what we wanted to allow this
shouldn't be happening in a stonewall
setup so the mistake probably came
earlier
okay so i have a theory which is that
the mistake is here
and that we should have gone
with the maybe the immediate h6
maybe the immediate h6 was was more
prudent again knight f7 is not scary
king f7
white has to play knight g and now
knight d5 this okay this is what we
should have done knight d5 and you're
attacking e3 now you're ready to play f5
i think this is
this is where we went wrong i think
bishop b7 i kind of fell asleep and all
of a sudden after 94
white's pieces coordinate very nicely
just shows you how quickly things can
change
right out of nowhere and now i missed
entirely the concept of queen c2 to b3
just totally missed it
all of a sudden black can get made it
here in like two seconds
can you show more of this dangerous line
yeah so so what what is going on here
right and it's very important
i think one area in which you can
improve is is actually embracing these
chaotic positions rather than saying
this is too confusing for me i'm gonna
tune out
saying i'm going to examine this bit by
bit until i understand what's happening
in this position so what is happening in
this position how do we
wrap our heads around such a chaotic
well chaotic positions are chaotic
because there's
like four or five different specific
things that are happening and just gotta
break them down first of all the queen
is hanging right that's number one fact
one the queen is hanging
fact two
black is up a piece so
if black moves the queen away and then
consolidates will be up a piece
fact three the knight on e4 is hanging
and it's attacked by two different
pieces
so no matter where you put the queen the
knight will have maximum one defender
which means it can be recaptured
white's knight also has a defender
which means it can't cannot you cannot
win this knight
by moving the queen somewhere because
it's defended by a rook
that's what i
saw
and then i i started calculating and i
said well queen h4 looks pretty natural
after bishop takes e4 i noticed the
standoff between the bishops and
the moment you notice that you should
see the discovery
so i calculated this and then this and i
thought we're good
and i forgot to incorporate fact four
which is the fact that if white gets the
queen of b3 this creates the the the
disastrous threat of a smothered mate
and and a bunch of incredibly unpleasant
discoveries even if you find a way to
prevent it
so whatever random move this is the
smothered mate that is threatening
so you might say well knowing this why
don't we move our queen somewhere to
prevent queen b3 so queen d5 comes to
mind
but now bishop takes c4 happens with
tempo
and this is even worse
and now if we try knight takes d4 which
is a ridiculous move but should be
considered because it counter attacks
the queen
here after takes takes
at the very least white has a draw
check this is a double check
and then back to f7 so at least why does
it draw that i already ruled that out
just because of that
some of you suggested just queen e7
but apart from queen b3 even here white
can just play bishop take c4 and i
didn't see a good follow-up white is up
a pawn and
lots of threats on this diagonal
taking the knight for the rook queen is
yeah so
you can say well i can get a rook and a
piece for the queen
the reason this is out of the question
is because of the st status of black's
king the king is way too weak here
what i'll do with white is i'll give a
check
i'll cover the escape square and then
i'll get this bishop out and get the
rook into the game and you're gonna get
mated in like two seconds here
yeah so
what you're saying sorry i can't read
your
ebenedeck
what you're saying is
yeah after queen h4 bishop b4 knight d4
ed4
we have to take with a queen we have to
create an a stronger threat of checkmate
which i thought forces white to trade
but
at the end of the day after takes e5
well we kind of have to recapture
otherwise we're down a pawn
we just get an opposite colored bishop
end game that's just dead draw
dead draw i mean symmetrical pawn
structure and white's pieces are
excellent
if anything thank you slim gee i
appreciate it if anything white's sort
of in the driver's seat here
but it's a draw to draw so it shows you
that i also fail to notice
certain things about certain positions
any other questions about this position
and like what's going on here
what was the solution oh yeah i forgot
to mention i was really terrified of
this move
i i think this might have won the game
for white because it threatens a
smothered mate
at first you might say oh we can go
knight a5 right we can attack the queen
which is the classic way of dealing with
the discovery but this is again a double
check which means you have to move the
king by definition
and now again you get smothered mated
what is the defense and this is a very
good trick that you guys should know
if you're ever in a situation where
your opponent threatens smothered mate
like this
there often is a defense but there's
only one move you can play that actually
prolongs the game and i've had a very
similar situation once where i was able
to save the game because i knew this
trick
look at this and it's very simple but if
you don't know it you might you might
actually panic this is from the world
youth under
10. first world youth i was playing the
eventual champion he's now a gm
this position
occurred on the board i was playing
black
and he's just played knight g5 he played
knight g5 and offered me a draw i took
it
because i was terrified
but the very simple move h6 defends
against everything knight f7 check
just k7 and you're safe
and you're safe and i thought that he
was able to make a draw here with knight
g5 check i thought this was perpetual so
this is an honest mistake
but after h takes g5 queen h3 check
black is able to escape the checks who
can tell me how
well this is why i saw that a draw was
happening right i thought okay i cannot
escape the checks
i go here he goes here i go here he goes
here we have a draw but you go king g6
after queen e6 check that bishop on b2
comes back to f6
stopping all of the checks and black is
a p sub there's no checks on this
diagonal because the queen is guarding
them
so
remember this trick of pushing up the h
pawn and opening up a square for your
king
now it's a lot more complicated in the
game but it's the same principle
you can play the move h6 or h5
and now you have a square
but my intuition is telling me that
white must have something here
i i wasn't a gm in 2005 my friend i was
1800
this was
17 years ago so for example bishop takes
c4 maybe is possible here in queenie
let's check with the engine
the engine's about to laugh at
everything i've ever done in my life but
it's fine
so let's see if the computer
yeah so
what black is better here a little bit
queen e7 yeah simply queen e7 the
computer prefers to to reinforce the
thread if i wasn't stubborn enough
i was not stubborn enough e4 is now a
very big threat
so we played b6 which
is not great wow our opponent found
the top of knight g5 that is just that
is really strong
okay it's still equal
it's still not bad rook fade oh no 94 is
fine
i mean but it's a draw oh queen h4 is a
draw no so queen h we played correctly
queen b3
and h6 is okay but rookie 7 gives a draw
wow rookie seven and that's another way
to defend against the smother mid
because now the f7 square is
independently protected by the rook
and black wins
so this is chaotic
wow what a perpendicular five check
white just has to come back and take the
knight then we take the pawn rook f4
intermezzo
and apparently the engine is showing
some sort of a repetition is inevitable
wow
so
technically we didn't do anything to
wrong this game it's just that he played
well
yeah queen e4 and
as the computer indicates this is just a
draw yeah this is a terrible move
queen f8 queen f2 is a terrible move
and
yeah queen d5 very accurate
and notice that c5
is the top move so rook f8 is also good
no rook f8 is not the top move
g5 is good but c5 nah this is here here
already anything wins and you shouldn't
put too much talk into what the engine
says
yeah that was a really uh
really
rich game even though it wasn't the the
the critical moment didn't last for very
long
a question to the earlier position is
after b6 black's
a what what on bishop b5
yeah i'm surprised more of you weren't
afraid of this move because the knight
is now not protected by a pawn i was
planning to sack pawn i was planning to
just go bishop d7
i was planning to sack the pawn
this is a high level positional
sacrifice because you just give up upon
what do you get in a turn you get a
light square bishop so you get a lot of
light square control and you potentially
get a battery against the g2 pawn
without the light squad bishop white is
really struggling to protect
a lot of these squares in the center
that can be used by the knight by the
queen
i think most of you can understand where
the compensation is coming from here i
thought practically speaking this is a
good attempt
no i think this was not a bad game i
don't i didn't i played not nearly as
badly as i thought
and uh it's just largely because i
went for this very slow b6 idea
and that's where we're going to end it's
late i have rcc commentary
i still have to finish a couple things
tonight so i've got
my work it out for me
thank you everybody appreciate your
support
and i'll see you guys later
[Music]